okay gibt es doch bestimmt auch
mitbekommen das licht aus unseren handys
tablet computer bildschirm soll blauer
sein als für uns gut ist zumindest gibt
es inzwischen einige produkte die gegen
blaues licht helfen diese produkte
sollen verhindern dass bildschirme uns
um unseren schlaf bringen dass sie
unsere augen ruinieren oder dass sie
unsere haut altern lassen vielleicht
habe ich auch deswegen den gelben
hintergrund gewählt damit ihr nicht so
sehr belastet werde durch dieses video
gehen wir der sache auf den grund und
schauen uns an inwieweit blaues licht
unsere haut unsere augen und unseren
schlaf beeinflusst und ob euer blau
filter im handy irgend etwas bringt
[Musik]
zuerst mal die basics als fleißige mal
der zuschauer wisst ihr ja bestimmt
licht besteht aus elektromagnetischen
wellen einer bestimmten wellenlänge
sehen können wir das nicht nur innerhalb
eines kleinen wellenlängenbereich es von
etwa 380 bis 780 nanometer
das kurzwellige licht ist violett dann
kommt blauen dann alle anderen farben
des regenbogens tageslicht oder auch das
licht aus dieser lampe hat einen mix aus
allen fahrern sieht daher für uns weiß
aus der ältere glühbirne strahlt er so
gelblich orangefarbenes licht aus weil
diese lampen eben mehr licht in diesen
wellenlängen aussenden die moderneren
leds aber auch die bildschirme unserer
handys tablet computer haben einen
stärkeren anteil an blauem licht seit es
diese bildschirme gibt gucken wir alle
also stärker ins blaue jetzt ja und
jetzt holt ihr euch mal ein tier denn
das haben wir doch alles vor uns also
macht es euch gemütlich lässt blaues
licht die haut altern leute den jogging
digital aging ist das stichwort dieses
video alter deine haut es gibt jetzt
cremes gegen klaus licht trip bluelight
ging blue lights okay was ist also
gerade im sommer merken ja viele das
licht schlecht für die haut sein kann
nämlich zu viel sonnenlicht gibt
sonnenbrand das liegt an der uv
strahlung die uv strahlung liegt im
elektromagnetischen spektrum neben dem
sichtbaren licht aus
nach dem violetten licht kommt das
ultraviolette licht uv und das ist
ebenso kurzweilig dass wir es nicht mehr
sehen können aber so energiereich dass
es zum beispiel krebs verursachen können
und nicht nur das gerade das etwas
länger wellige uva licht kann die haut
altern lassen und zwar indem sie in den
hautzellen oxidativen stress verursacht
jetzt ist seit einiger zeit bekannt dass
auch blaues sichtbares licht ähnliche
reaktionen in der haut auslösen kann
also auch die haut altern kann zwar
nicht so intensiv aber doch messbar was
machen wir jetzt dagegen gegen uv-licht
wissen wir uns ja zu schützen da gibt es
ja sonnencremes die funktionieren dem
sie uv-licht entweder reflektieren oder
indem sie das uv licht absorbieren und
in wärme umwandeln so oder so die haut
wird vor dem uv-licht geschützt das
sonnencremes aber nicht vor sichtbarem
licht schützen sehen wir übrigens daran
dass sonnencremes unsichtbar sind je
nach sonnencreme haben wir halt leichte
lichtreflektionen das heißt es glänzt
ein bisschen die haut aber ansonsten
geht das sichtbare licht einfach durch
die sonnencreme durch doch jetzt gibt
solche krems die angeblich auch noch vor
blauem licht schützen gegen die changing
wie gesagt doch diese bluelight krems
funktionieren nicht wie sonnencreme also
sie sind keine schutzschilder gegen
klaus nicht denn wenn die das wäre wenn
sie zum beispiel wirklich blaues licht
reflektieren würden dann würden die
cremes nämlich auch blaue aussehen auf
der haut stattdessen sollen diese cremes
einfach nur antioxidativ wirken und so
die hautalterung aufhalten oder verlang
war sehr enttäuschend
wie so oft bei kosmetischen artikeln
doch es gibt noch einen wichtigeren
grund warum diese digital aging idee
nicht ganz schlüssig ist denn blaues
licht kommt ja nicht nur aus diesem
bildschirm das tageslicht da draußen
enthält natürlich auch sehr viel blaues
licht selbst an einem bewölkten tag
bekommen wir noch 30 mal mehr blaues
licht ab als für unseren bildschirm das
heißt selbst wenn klaus licht zur
hautalterung beiträgt dann haben unsere
bildschirme nur einen kleinen anteil
und das krems verkauft werden die ganz
speziell für digital aging als für das
aging durch eure bildschirme gemacht
sind ist mal wieder nicht mehr als ein
marketing gag gesagt zweitens schadet
blaues licht den augen zu starkes licht
kann die augen verletzen deswegen sollte
man im sommer eine sonnenbrille tragen
und auch nicht mit bloßem auge eine
sonnenfinsternis beobachten
verantwortlich für diese schäden ist zum
einen die uv-strahlung genauso wie zu
viel uv licht die haut verbrennen kann
kann zu viel uv licht auch unsere augen
verbrennen und auch langfristig kann
uv-licht das risiko für bestimmte
augenkrankheiten eröffnen aber nicht nur
das uv licht sondern auch das sichtbare
licht kann die augen schädigen und
blaues licht ganz besonders es gibt
deswegen sogar internationale richtwerte
für blaulicht intensität aber keine
sorge dieser bildschirm liegt etwa 100
fach darunter aber zu helles sichtbares
licht kann kleine schäden in der
netzhaut verursachen die an sich erstmal
gar nicht so schlimm sind doch forscher
gehen davon aus dass mit jedem kleinen
scharner netzhaut das risiko steigt für
eine bestimmte augenerkrankung nämlich
die altersbedingte makuladegeneration
die tritt vor allem bei senioren auf und
kann bis zur erblindung führen schutz
vor blauem licht könnte das risiko für
so eine makuladegeneration senken doch
die wissenschaftliche datenlage ist da
leider zum beispiel manche menschen
bekommen bei einer augenerkrankung vom
augenarzt eine neue linse implantiert
und oft benutzt man hier eine linse mit
blau filter um das risiko für einen
makler die generation zu senken wenn man
das jetzt aber versucht wissenschaftlich
zu vergleichen oder es mal schaut was
für studien ist da gibt es zum vergleich
da fand man zumindest nach anderthalb
jahren zwischen patienten mit normaler
linse und patient mit lauter linse kein
unterschied und für irgendwelche
weiteren aussagen gibt es tatsächlich
leider keine belastbaren daten
das heißt in der theorie ist das ganze
plausibel darunter praxis gibt es wenig
wissenschaftliche belege also blaues
licht kann den augen schaden aber nach
wie vor ist da draußen doch vielmehr
blaues licht als wir von unseren
bildschirm abbekommen und selbst wenn
die abschirmung von blauem licht
ihre augen länger gesund halten könnte
dann hätte der abendliche blau filter
sicherlich kein besonders großen anteil
daran
drittens hält uns blaues licht abends
wach anders gefragt lässt uns unser
handy lichts schlechter schlafen naja
wir bereits aus unserem video über eulen
und lerchen also über spät und
frühaufsteher wisst stellt schlicht
unsere innere uhr in einem gewissen
rahmen könnt ihr eure uhr verstellen und
zwar am besten mit licht das sieht man
sehr deutlich an studien wie diese hier
stärkte man sich paar versuchsteilnehmer
und ließ sie tagelang bei schummrigem
licht drinnen sitzen wie kamen die
teilnehmer morgens oder tagsüber eine
stunde lang eine volle dröhnung helles
licht stellten sich die inneren uhren
vor dh sie gingen früher zu bett doch
bekamen die teilnehmer dieses licht
abends oder nachts stellten sich die
uhren nach das heißt sie gingen später
ins bett und die heller das licht desto
stärker der effekt das gute ist wenn ihr
euren oder spätaufsteher seid und eure
innere uhr früher stellen wollt dann
müsst ihr euch nicht morgens von der
sonne wirken lassen wie manche nach
unserem letzten video befürchtet haben
also ab in die sonne freunde der sonne
tageslicht oder möglichst helles licht
später am tag zum beispiel in der
mittagspause hat den gleichen effekt das
schlecht ist wenn ihr abends schlafen
könnt und dann auch noch ins helle
smartphone schaut macht ihr alles noch
viel schlimmer
und jetzt kommt das blaue licht ins
spiel denn für unsere innere uhr
wir können verschiedene farben
verschiedenen hell und blaues licht
wirkt heller als anders farbiges licht
das heißt wenn wir abends zum beispiel
der leselampe anmachen mit hohen gelb
anteil dann bringt das unseren inneren
rhythmus weniger durcheinander als in
led bildschirm mit höheren blauanteil
weil der heller wirkt als er eigentlich
ist das wurde zum beispiel in dieser
studie getestet hier nahmen neun leute
und untersuchte sie tagelang in einem
schlaflabor fünf tage lang beschäftigten
sich die versuchsteilnehmer vor dem
schlafengehen mit lesen das ist mit
einem buch oder einer zeitschrift ihrer
wahl und die nächsten fünf tage
beschäftigen sie sich mit ihrem tablet
mit tablett ging die teilnehmer im
schnitt eine halbe stunde später
schlafen gut jetzt könnte man natürlich
sagen tablets sind generell spannender
als bücher und deswegen weit man länger
wach aber dagegen spricht diese studie
wurde von derselben forschungsgruppe
durchgeführt nur dieses mal haben sie
die templeton buch zeit genau gleich
gehalten und nach dem buch schliefen die
leute im schnitt noch 15 minuten ein
nach dem tablet schliefen sie im schnitt
erst nach 25 minuten nach fünf tagen
waren die inneren uhren der tablet user
um ganze anderthalb stunden verschoben
so was kann man messen
anhand des so genannten schlafhormons
melatonin nachts youtube macht uns also
zu stärkeren eulen also zu stärkeren
spät aufstehen jetzt leben wir natürlich
nicht in schlaf geboren das heißt ob
dieser effekt auch im alltag so groß ist
das hängt auch davon ab was ihr sonst so
macht für eure innere uhr gilt je mehr
licht also am besten tageslicht geht
tagsüber ab bekommt desto weniger macht
es auch aus wenn die abends ein bisschen
zu viel licht oder handy licht usw
gehabt in dieser studie sorgt man dafür
dass die teilnehmer tagsüber sehr viel
hellem licht ausgesetzt waren und fand
dann abends keinen nennenswerten
unterschied zwischen den teilnehmern die
ein buch vom schlafen gehen lassen
von welchen die dasselbe buch auf einem
tablett lassen okay aber was bringen
jetzt wirklich diese blaue filter leider
ist die datenlage hier auch nicht viel
besser als bei den augen in dieser
kleinen studie
diese man die teilnehmer abends mit oder
ohne blaue filter youtube videos gucken
oder spiele spielen und fand keinen
nennenswerten unterschied andere studien
wiederum finden eine unterschied man
müsste einfach größere und methodisch
bessere studien durchführen um da
wirklich eine aussage treffen zu können
aber wenn wir schon speziell über blaues
licht reden müssen wir eine sache
beachten bei einem handy oder tablet
fällt uns generell viel mehr licht ins
auge als bei einem buch mit lesen ab in
der studie von vorhin kam von dem tablet
etwa 50 mal mehr licht ins auge als von
der leselampe und wie gesagt nicht nur
blaues licht sondern nicht im
allgemeinen verstellt unsere innere uhr
außerdem können wir uns wahrscheinlich
einig sein dass youtube und instagram
und chor uns auch wach halten unabhängig
vom nicht sagen wir so es ist sicher
dass uns
handys laptops tablets war halten nur
welchen anteil daran das blaue licht hat
das können wir momentan nicht so genau
sagen das gesamtfazit es spricht nichts
gegen blau filter nur solltet ihr nicht
glauben dass sie jetzt damit fein raus
seid die die hinter blau filtern ist
wissenschaftlich plausibel aber nicht
wissenschaftlich belegt dass sie mit
euch benutzt ihr blau filter und schau
dir gerade dieses video obwohl er
eigentlich schlafen solltet wenn ja dann
erst schlafen und zweitens haben wir auf
social video falls das noch nicht denn
wenn ihr ernsthaft dieses video schaut
anstatt zu schlafen
dann wird euch das auch gefallen aber im
ernst geht schlafen
wir sehen uns nächste woche bis dahin
bleibt sicher